you look good you are a you're a sharp
dresser I didn't know you went this
casual because I I feel like I'm you're
like business manager you know we should
talk about an estate plan I know we'll
get to a John you're always worried
you're always worried but you do you
look you you always look sharp you don't
think you really do
I don't know this suit this suit fits
now I'm gonna be thin for eight more
months I think like it's already
starting to go gonna go in what way I
can hide it like people go you're thin
but I'm like I know where the fat is
it's hidden in weird pocket where is
your fat specifically well my body's
like the apartment of a drug dealer like
at first you're like there's no cashier
but then you're like tear open the couch
and there's nine hundred thousand not
gonna tell you the rest I just got I got
I got fat in strange place now are you
saying that you think you're going to
what is this based on that you think in
nine months a year or a couple years
from now you're gonna be eight months
was the figure I threw out Wow you are
my business manager yeah honestly I'd
start prepping for it do you what makes
you think that you are going to get
heavy bad nutrition lack of exercise and
and people and my wife and everyone I've
ever met says you should stop smoking
and when I stopped smoking I think I'll
gain weight yeah and then what I don't
do is exercise or eat well so it'll all
come together
right right well I'm looking forward to
that yeah well I'll you know I'll wear a
Hawaiian shirt and be fun and you know
you got some some news from the doctor
recently that you were going to share
with us is that correct oh well I have a
labral tear in my hip which is ya know
you never think it's gonna be you and
then the MRI comes out and you have it
now yeah you know I was very grateful
and it's a tear that ballerinas normally
get but I got it and my dog also has it
my dog has mild hip dysplasia and so do
I so and what did you bring you brought
us something right yes I believe I have
a bit of my the full Hospital for
Special Surgery the port on my hip and
pelvis yeah yeah
[Applause]
what every man wants to hear love you
it's not outside it's it's unremarkable